pas
j'ai mal à ma patrie en avril c'est le
titre de la chanson emblématique que
luis enrique mejia godeuil a composé
quelques jours à peine après la
manifestation monstre du 18 avril 2018
elle a marqué le début de la révolte
massive des nicaraguayens contre le
gouvernement du président daniel ortega
qui imposait une réforme des retraites
jugée injuste mais prions maintenant
bon boulot lors des samedis
mais là parce que quatre mois plus tard
et des centaines de manifestations de
barricader d'affrontements les ong on
comptait plus de 400 morts de sa gueule
c'est moi
[Musique]
luis enrique mais fait à grenoble est un
artiste engagé depuis plus de 50 ans il
chante le nicaragua un troubadour de la
révolution sandiniste qui a renversé le
dictateur anastasio somoza et suscité de
l'admiration dans le monde luis enrique
et de ses chanteurs dont tout le monde
connaît les paroles de ses chansons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il s'est nourri qui arrive de calgary il
donnera ensuite des concerts à ottawa
san francisco los angeles chicago
ce soir il se produit à montréal il
n'est pas ici uniquement comme artiste
il porte un message
je suis venu ici pour dénoncer tout ce
qui se passe au nicaragua je ne suis ni
politicien ni politologue et ni candidat
à quoi que ce soit je ne suis qu'un
chanteur du peuple nos peurs callas
dauphin l'inter je ne peux pas me taire
devant tant d'injustices de terreur de
crimes de répression contre les jeunes
surtout contre les jason la route au
contrat
les affrontements ont cessé au nicaragua
mais les manifestations continuent le
président daniel ortega semble avoir
repris le dessus
ortega essaie de tout effacer
on efface tout et on recommence à zéro
ils appellent ça la normalité du pays
il a fait une opération nettoyage comme
le faisait le dictateur somoza ortega
parle d'une bataille du loup reuze
contre une conspiration armés internes
et des forces externes aussi bien connu
il vise la droite du pays et les états
unis
les opposants n'avaient pas d'armes dit
luis enrique il était sandiniste comme
daniel ortega il est toujours mais j'ai
honte face à mes petits enfants dit je
leur ai promis un pays libre et je n'ai
pas tenu ma promesse
c'est eux qui ont la parole maintenant
leur caterina parole on m'a déjà dit que
c'est une bataille de sandiniste contre
sandiniste
non elle s'en est même en contre l année
non c'est le sandiniste contrôler le
tagne l'isthme ou leur égoïsme union of
avril le 18 avril a changé l'histoire du
nicaragua pour toujours elle ne sera
jamais plus là mêmes qui tirent bien
même
les nouveautés
quand nous y aurait cinq gripen et la
primavera veste au courant c'est garros
où visa ça qu'elle dessine
luis enrique chante devant une salle
pleine à montréal beaucoup de
nicaraguayens en exil et sympathisants
québécois également ce qui leur demande
c'est de la solidarité et pour
nicaraguayen de rester unis en soutien à
ce petit pays rebelles héroïque un
peuple vaillant noble travailleurs
aujourd'hui on essaie de faire croire
que ce peuplement que tout est inventé
qu'il ne s'est rien passé
c'est ce que dit le président quand il a
écrit la chanson mi avril il y avait eu
40 morts
on en compte quatre sort maintenant
malgré tout le chanteur se dit optimiste
pour l'avenir un avenir sans daniel
ortega
[Applaudissements]